all right so Venom's out spoiler warning
for venom you haven't seen venom maybe
you don't want to watch this if you have
seen venom which is likely it actually
wrecked into pretty good money which is
impressive considering critics [ __ ]
hated it fans seem to be kind of torn
but a lot of people liked if you see my
review you know my stance on venom venom
the character was actually really cool
the movie around venom more specifically
the antagonist element I felt could have
been better that's where the staple
comes in we're going to talk about that
this was actually going to be my venom
spoiler talk video and I thought venom
is a pretty straightforward movie Venom
symbiote Eddie Brock come together form
venom generic science guy becomes riot
then venom stabs his rocket and kills up
the end and sexy venom oh my god when
Michele Williams had the Venom symbiote
she walks up to about wow I found myself
a new van is a how many of you out there
when you got home were like she venom
hot Google Images how many I know you
did bless you however the post credit
scene was legit a great post credit
scene setting it up to talk about I want
to see in the sequel the post credits
scenes shows Eddie Brock and he's going
to a prison right there I was like oh
Cletus Kasady
has to be actually I had forgotten to
this point that Woody Harrelson was
talked about being in this movie people
are like he's got to be Cletus Kasady
towards that you see the back of his
head these curly locks you see this red
hair he turns around it's like Woody
Harrelson with this Annie wig he's all
it cracked me up I know Cletus Kasady
has wild red hair but if he does get a
haircut for the sequel I wouldn't hate
it it was a little much the point is
he's like when I get out of here you're
just gonna be carnage big cut the black
if you didn't already know he was Cletus
Kasady you now know he is because Cletus
Kasady is carnage and that to me is the
iconic venom enemy right there they had
to bring him for the sequel that's kind
of a kin to at the end of Batman Begins
Gordon gives Batman this card he flips
it over to Joker card I'm out swinging
for the sequel man which I'm actually
thrilled that Woody Harrelson is Cletus
gas he's a little older than I would
have thought but I am pretty sure in the
90s in a world where these Marvel movies
might not have ever happened ever I mean
now here they are they're definitely
happened comic book movies are the thing
of movies but in junior high in high
school for me all we had was my friends
and I talking about who we'd like to see
play who that was like a Woody Harrelson
from Natural Born Killers would be
perfect cleanest Cassidy
so I feel like it took two and a half
decades but childhood me got really
validated just now point is alright
carnage for the venom sequel so what do
I want to say first of all you have to
make that one rated R I do feel venom
could have benefited from being rated R
but hey it works with pg-13 obviously a
good box office numbers but I don't know
how you do carnage without an R rating I
just legit don't regret it it could be
done Joker kills a lot of people and
using pg-13 movies maybe it's because I
read those spider-man novels that were
around in the 90s and in the novels that
were a little more graphic than the
comic books wore to a particular carnage
in New York and goblins revenge had
carnage in them and he was a [ __ ]
bloodthirsty maniac bastard this is the
descriptions there's the scene where he
takes all these guns from these guards
here's all these guns to their heads
kind of like magneto from the first
x-men movie but imagine carnage tendrils
around all the triggers he just pulls
the triggers and bam it just describes
brain matter splattering on everybody
another scene he's in this plane he
wants to take off he goes to this guy
and literally pulls his head off and
drops his headless body back in his
chair goes over to the terminal holds up
the head and bows the head down the
terminal is described like a bloody
soggy football it lands at someone's
feet it's just pretty graphic and those
are the images I have with carnage I
don't know how you don't show [ __ ] like
that in a carnage movie and I don't know
how you do show that and make it pg-13
has to be art I also want to see carnage
be tied to venom I want the carnage
symbiote to be an offspring of the Venom
symbiote I know it kind of seems like I
will no [ __ ] that's how it is in the
comic book kind of situation but you
know how movies are always changing
comic book lore and kind of fudging it
to make it fit into a movie whatever
they fudge whatever they change they
just can't change that the carnage
symbiote needs to remain the offspring
of the Venom symbiote it can't just be
something that came from space that came
from the comet or something like that
ended up here on to cletus kasady now
he's carnies just killing people but at
that point venom taking him down he's
like he's just taking down any villain
really there's no bond there's no
feeling of responsibility there's no
weight on their shoulder but keeping the
lore of the carnage symbiote being the
offspring of the Venom symbiote there's
a feeling of responsibility there
there's a guilt there's weight it's a
powerful thing and I hope they play that
up and it will be like we can't run from
this fight because there's a direct
causality there there's a direct link
without us
there would be no hit Venom's not gonna
run from the responsibility of taking
down the villain after he created him so
why did you loop gun to my head I don't
think they're gonna change that lore for
the
but it is something I'm really looking
forward to saying that would add an
element of depth to venom and I think
the movie fandom could benefit from but
really I feel like with this venom
sequel which I feel like we might
actually get it is the opportunity to
fix what I didn't like about the venom
movie thing I didn't like most about the
movie was too generic antagonists now
for the sequel you have carnage this
mass-murdering antagonist that venom
feels responsible for it takes care of
that right there it's a really powerful
dynamic carnage is strong he's powerful
he is a vicious bastard cletus kasady
Woody Harrelson's character he's a
serial killer he killed his own grandma
it was a maniac before the carnage
symbiote got onto him there's no
conflict there's no fight for control
between Cletus Kasady and the symbiote
no no he's giving himself over to it
he's actually so bonded to carnage he
says I it's not we are carnage it is I'm
carnage because the two have become one
and he's even more insane and
bloodthirsty now that he's carnage than
he was when he was Cletus Kasady and he
could tell from the post-credits scene
he's a bit nuts already you think
they're gonna call it carnage Unleashed
or maximum carnage there's literally no
reason to not call it maximum carnage I
feel like this venom movie is the only
venom Mulligan that venom is gonna get
so this venom sequel coming out is the
only carnage movie we're actually ever
gonna get might as well call it maximum
carnage in any case I hope you had a
good time in venom and I hope we have a
good time with the venom snake I'm
looking forward to seeing carnage I'm
looking forward to seeing venom taking
on carnage I've literally wanted to see
this since the 90s so this is like
Christmas for me the venom movie that we
have as a Santa is the first one it's
not perfect but there's an enjoyment in
there so here's hoping they do carnage
right arse of carnage in the venom
sequel what do you think about that
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]